Jack: 你就之前在开始之前跑那个
Jack: Just run the one you ran before.
Nicous: 哎我没有啊
Nicous: Hey, I don't have it.
Nicous: 就我们课堂我们那个
Nicous: In our class, we...
Nicous: 然后就是Outlook然后他全都直接有
Nicous: And then with Outlook, it all directly has it.
Shure: 等一下
Shure: Wait a second.
Jack: 怎么怎么没有interview
Jack: Why is there no interview?
Shure: 哎呦我操
Shure: Oh, shit.
Jack: 哎我这是这是petrol吗
Jack: Hey, is this petrol?
Shure: 这是petrol吗
Shure: Is this petrol?
Jack: 上一次用petrol还是大二
Jack: Last time I used petrol was sophomore year.
Jake:1500
Jake: 1500.
Jake:2024
Jake: 2024.
Shure: 我早开了
Shure: I've already opened it.
Jack: 你用petrol吗
Jack: Do you use petrol?
Jack: 你给他配一下petrol
Jack: Configure petrol for him.
Nicous: petrol太好配了啊
Nicous: Petrol is so easy to configure.
Shure: 来来来他就会蹦出来这个
Shure: Come on, it will just pop up.
Choiszt: 傻瓜教学
Choiszt: Foolproof tutorial.
Shure: 不我环境都没好呢
Shure: No, my environment isn't even set up yet.
Nicous: 啊啊我错了哥
Nicous: Ah, my bad, bro.
Shure: yes
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 然后他会给我报这个
Shure: Then it will report this.
Shure: trouble shooting some counter package install
Shure: Troubleshooting some counter package install.
Shure: 啦啦啦for example
Shure: La la la, for example.
Jack: 不你你现在create一个新环境
Jack: No, you should create a new environment now.
Shure: 啊可以
Shure: Ah, okay.
Jack: 对你create
Jack: Yes, create one.
Jack: 就是缺什么装什么
Jack: Just install whatever is missing.
Jack: 绝对最快
Jack: It's the fastest way.
Jack: 相信我绝对最快
Jack: Trust me, it's the fastest.
Katrina: 你要不要去拿个勺子
Katrina: Do you want to get a spoon?
Lucia: 还有勺吗
Lucia: Do we have any more spoons?
Katrina: 嗯放那个厨房里
Katrina: Yeah, they're in the kitchen.
Katrina: 有勺在那
Katrina: There are some spoons there.
Shure: 我相信你们的
Shure: I trust you guys.
Jack: 你就随便可以
Jack: Just do whatever.
Jack: 你看看你拍摄的版本也行
Jack: You can also check the version you filmed.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Shure: 就跟我那个本地那个一模一样的
Shure: It's exactly the same as the local one.
Shure: 这都是不是
Shure: All of these, right?
Nicous: 不是
Nicous: No.
Nicous: 他这玩意只给你下那种正正版的软件
Nicous: This thing only lets you download the official software.
Nicous: 然后他是那种
Nicous: And then it's like...
Choiszt: 但是你没有激活码
Choiszt: But you don't have an activation code.
Nicous: 对啊而且
Nicous: Yeah, plus...
Nicous: 他问有没有那个微软的365
Nicous: He asked if you have Microsoft 365.
其他人：我也没有
Others: I don't have it either.
Jake:微软的链接
Jake: A Microsoft link.
Jake:我也没有码
Jake: I don't have a code either.
Jack: 我有码我有账号
Jack: I have a code, I have an account.
Jack: 我可以一会
Jack: I can...
Jack: 一会今天晚
Jack: Later tonight...
Jack: 上回来发给你
Jack: I'll send it to you.
Choiszt: 你发我就行
Choiszt: Just send it to me.
Nicous: 你也我也我也我也我也
Nicous: You too, you too, you too, you too.
Nicous: 快毕业了不
Nicous: Are we about to graduate?
Choiszt: 你那个码是哪来的
Choiszt: Where did you get that code from?
Jack: 腾讯呗哈哈哈
Jack: From Tencent, haha.
Nicous: 发我我用一个
Nicous: Send it to me, I'll use it.
Choiszt: 能用吗
Choiszt: Will it work?
Choiszt: 找你买一条
Choiszt: I'll buy one from you.
Jack: 看不到他就是一个激活账号
Jack: You can't see it, it's just an activation account.
Choiszt: 真可以用吗
Choiszt: Can it really be used?
Jake:我们准备买东西
Jake: We're preparing to buy some stuff.
Jake:我们要买什么呢
Jake: What should we buy?
Jake:我们还要补一些
Jake: We need to get some more...
Nicous: 我们的world就是
Nicous: Our world is...
Jake:还有谁要补
Jake: Who else needs more?
Jake:你有要补的东西吗
Jake: Do you need to get anything?
Jake:你要补酒吗
Jake: Do you need to get more wine?
Shure: 补点
Shure: Just a bit.
Jake:补点
Jake: Add some more.
Jake:你还要补啥
Jake: What else do you need to add?
Jack: 你如果没激活你那啥也打不了
Jack: If you haven't activated it, you can't do anything.
Jake:你琢磨琢磨
Jake: Think about it.
其他人：然后他这个都是同同步的所以
Others: And then it's all synced up so...
Jake:路亚要补点什么吗
Jake: Does Lua need to add anything?
Jake:补什么
Jake: Add what?
Jake:补货
Jake: Restock.
Jake:我们要买东西的话要补什么货吗
Jake: If we need to buy something, do we need to restock anything?
Jake:雨轩要补货吗
Jake: Yuxuan, do we need to restock?
Katrina: 我思考一下
Katrina: Let me think about it.
Lucia: 如果有蓝色系的明信片的话或者
Lucia: If there are blue-themed postcards, or...
Katrina: 你找找我那明信片里面有没有蓝色的
Katrina: Check if there are any blue ones among my postcards.
Lucia: 对也可以就地取材一下
Lucia: Yeah, we can just use what's available.
Shure: 变成那个康纳的那个环境来着
Shure: It turned into Connor's environment.
Lucia: 我觉得我那个照片
Lucia: I think my photo...
Lucia: 墙上可能需要戳两个
Lucia: The wall might need a couple of marks.
Lucia: 但是当时好像买了也来不及
Lucia: But it seems like it was too late to buy them at that time.
Lucia: 太不太来得及到
Lucia: It's probably too late now.
Jake:这玩意要收起来哦
Jake: This thing needs to be put away.
Jake:可以收
Jake: It can be put away.
Katrina: 美文旺仔牛奶是不是要买
Katrina: Should we buy some Meiwang milk?
Katrina: 美文纸跟旺仔牛奶是吧
Katrina: Meiwang paper and Wangzai milk, right?
Lucia: 美文纸我买了
Lucia: I bought the Meiwang paper.
Lucia: 他今天应该到了
Lucia: It should arrive today.
Lucia: 我看看啊
Lucia: Let me check.
Katrina: 那那旺仔牛奶是不是要外送
Katrina: Should we deliver the Wangzai milk?
Katrina: 要大概几瓶
Katrina: How many bottles roughly?
Katrina: 那就买那种一板行不行
Katrina: How about buying a whole tray?
Jake:我们来记个小本本
Jake: Let's make a note of it.
Nicous: 可是他妈才创
Nicous: But it just started.
Nicous: 然后一个没创进去啊
Nicous: And nothing has been created yet.
Katrina: 黑板可以拿出来了
Katrina: The blackboard can be taken out now.
Katrina: 哼
Katrina: Hmph.
Katrina: 户外教学
Katrina: Outdoor teaching.
Jack: 今天今天晚上教我配Alab的机器
Jack: Teach me how to set up the Alab machine tonight.
Choiszt: 你要配那个
Choiszt: You need to set up that...
Choiszt: 干啥
Choiszt: What for?
Jack: 干活再不干活就要干死我
Jack: If I don't work, it'll kill me.
Jack: 再不干活我就可以不干了
Jack: If I don't work, I might as well quit.
Jake:来个人抬黑板
Jake: Someone help me move the blackboard.
Jake:来来来
Jake: Come on, come on.
Nicous: 不是你每次每次
Nicous: Isn't it the same every time?
Nicous: 叼的是同一个吧
Nicous: You always pick the same one, right?
Choiszt: 可能吧
Choiszt: Maybe.
Lucia: 每次叼的是同一个
Lucia: Always picking the same one.
Nicous: 别他妈这一盒他妈全部给叼一个
Nicous: Don't take the whole box and pick just one!
Choiszt: 那就给我得了
Choiszt: Then just give it to me.
Choiszt: 我来跟别人social
Choiszt: I'll use it to socialize.
Choiszt: social通行
Choiszt: Social pass.
Nicous: 这一盒给你
Nicous: This box is yours.
Nicous: 八个
Nicous: Eight pieces.
Nicous: 转我20块钱就行
Nicous: Just transfer me 20 yuan.
Choiszt: 一共多少
Choiszt: How much in total?
Choiszt: 20根是吧嗯
Choiszt: 20 pieces, right? Hmm.
Choiszt: 我觉得可以
Choiszt: I think that's fine.
Choiszt: 买点槟榔给人送
Choiszt: Buy some betel nuts to gift people.
Nicous: 你是最傻逼吧
Nicous: Are you the dumbest?
Nicous: 你是想害人
Nicous: Are you trying to harm people?
Choiszt: 不是那你
Choiszt: No, but you...
Choiszt: 那你说能买
Choiszt: But you said we could buy...
Nicous: 巧克力吧
Nicous: Chocolate instead.
Jake:放边上吧
Jake: Put it on the side.
Jake:放放那个最左边
Jake: Put it on the far left.
Choiszt: 真晒呀
Choiszt: It's really sunny.
Katrina: 好搞笑
Katrina: So funny.
Choiszt: QA是什么
Choiszt: What's QA?
Katrina: 就是那是我写的and
Katrina: That's what I wrote and...
Katrina: 哈哈哈q and a我不太会画那个符号
Katrina: Haha, Q and A. I don't really know how to draw that symbol.
Katrina: 就是地球世界地球日的那个问答
Katrina: It's for the Earth Day Q&A.
Choiszt: 那还要准备问题吗
Choiszt: Do we need to prepare questions?
Jake:对要准备问题
Jake: Yes, we need to prepare questions.
Katrina: 哎写一下吧
Katrina: Oh, write it down.
Katrina: 中午那确实是问题吗
Katrina: Was that really a question at noon?
Lucia: 那只是大家讲的
Lucia: That's just what everyone said.
Jake:不孕不育会遗传吧
Jake: Infertility can be inherited, right?
Katrina: 哈哈黑板擦没拿是不是
Katrina: Haha, didn't we bring the blackboard eraser?
Katrina: 黑板擦没拿
Katrina: We didn't bring the blackboard eraser.
Katrina: 那黑板擦呢
Katrina: Where's the blackboard eraser?
Katrina: 我没找到嘛
Katrina: I couldn't find it.
Jake:有有有的
Jake: Yes, yes, we have it.
Katrina: 拿了
Katrina: Got it.
Katrina: 列一下吧
Katrina: Let's list it out.
Katrina: 美文纸买了是吧
Katrina: Did you buy the Meiwenzhi paper?
Katrina: 那就旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Then it's just Wangzai Milk.
Tasha: 美文纸买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy the Meiwenzhi paper?
Katrina: 他说他买
Katrina: He said he bought it.
Lucia: 应该到了
Lucia: It should have arrived.
Lucia: 我今天收到他
Lucia: I received it today.
Jake:黑板擦在哪
Jake: Where's the chalkboard eraser?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia: 什么这也是奇葩问题吗难道
Lucia: What, is this a weird question or something?
Katrina: 冰块也有了
Katrina: We also have ice cubes.
Katrina: 那就只要送旺仔
Katrina: So we just need to deliver Wangzai Milk.
Tasha: 等会去采购
Tasha: Let's go shopping later.
Katrina: 哦我们等会出去吗要
Katrina: Oh, are we going out later?
Tasha: 对啊我们等会要出去
Tasha: Yeah, we are going out later.
Katrina: 我们等会要出去买啊
Katrina: We are going out to buy stuff later?
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Jake:最近天太好了
Jake: The weather has been great lately.
Jack: http error g
Jack: HTTP error G.
Jake:http error没网
Jake: HTTP error, no internet.
Jake:服务器没网
Jake: The server has no internet.
Jack: 不他本地没网
Jack: No, his local connection has no internet.
Shure: 不是这是服务器的啊
Shure: No, it's the server's issue.
Katrina: 采购清单
Katrina: Shopping list.
Jake:没钱了
Jake: No money left.
Shure: 怎么可能
Shure: How is that possible?
Shure: 我今天早上刚给他充100
Shure: I just topped up 100 this morning.
Shure: 什么叫export
Shure: What does "export" mean?
Jack: 就你没开proxy吧
Jack: Maybe you didn't enable the proxy.
Jack: 下这么快呀
Jack: Downloading so fast, huh?
Jack: 哈哈哈一秒一秒跑
Jack: Haha, running at one second per second.
Jack: 90%还好
Jack: 90%, still good.
Shure: 这5005百k每秒的
Shure: This is 500k per second.
Shure: 不可能这绝逼是假的这个东西
Shure: No way, this must be fake.
Shure: 什么叫clash
Shure: What does "clash" mean?
Shure: cash是什么意思
Shure: What does "cash" mean?
Lucia: 原来那个文件夹是这个意思
Lucia: Oh, so that's what that folder means.
Katrina: 上次那个葡萄汁兑酒好喝吗
Katrina: Was that grape juice mixed with wine good last time?
Katrina: 上次他你喝的葡萄是吗微微
Katrina: Last time, did you drink grape, Tasha?
Lucia: 我觉得一般吧
Lucia: I thought it was just okay.
Katrina: 我感觉西柚的蛮好喝哦
Katrina: I think the grapefruit one is pretty good.
Lucia: 西柚的比葡萄的好喝一点
Lucia: The grapefruit one is a bit better than the grape.
Katrina: 那橙汁的我也觉得一般般
Katrina: I also think the orange juice one is just average.
Katrina: 那只买
Katrina: So we just buy...
Lucia: 上次买的是朗姆
Lucia: Last time we bought rum.
Lucia: 就是橙汁
Lucia: It was the orange juice.
Lucia: 其实应该兑龙舌兰的
Lucia: It should be mixed with tequila, actually.
Katrina: 哦我们现在有拿酒
Katrina: Oh, we have some liquor now.
Katrina: 那要不要再买一瓶气泡酒
Katrina: Should we buy another bottle of sparkling wine?
Lucia: 气泡酒还有一瓶
Lucia: There's still one bottle of sparkling wine left.
Jack: 买那个旺仔牛奶
Jack: Buy that Wangzai milk.
Lucia: 有一个那个金色的气泡酒
Lucia: There's a bottle of that golden sparkling wine.
Jack: 旺仔牛奶配百利甜
Jack: Wangzai milk with Baileys.
Lucia: 你要甜死我哈哈哈
Lucia: You're going to sweeten me to death, haha.
Katrina: 咱咱还有什么酒来着
Katrina: What other liquor do we have?
Katrina: 那一瓶是什么呀
Katrina: What’s that bottle?
Katrina: 还有什么酒
Katrina: What other liquor do we have?
Katrina: 气泡气泡的有一瓶
Katrina: There's a bottle of sparkling.
Katrina: 然后还有呢
Katrina: And what else?
Katrina: 还有就是朗姆的半瓶
Katrina: And half a bottle of rum.
Shure: 一个底了
Shure: Just a bit left.
Katrina: 那就是一些吃的
Katrina: So, just some snacks.
Shure: 你可以你是不是一会不去对吧
Shure: You’re not going later, right?
Nicous: 干嘛
Nicous: Why?
Shure: 买东西的话
Shure: If we’re buying things.
Nicous: 我去我去
Nicous: I’ll go, I’ll go.
Shure: 你别去你帮我把
Shure: Don’t go, help me with...
Nicous: 我不帮你搞
Nicous: I’m not helping you.
Shure: 你在这帮我搞环境吧
Shure: Help me with the setup here.
Nicous: 我不如去
Nicous: I’d rather go.
Lucia: 不过我觉得刚才谢冰竹说
Lucia: But I think what Xie Bingzhu said...
Lucia: 那个百利甜值得考虑
Lucia: That Baileys is worth considering.
Lucia: 因为感觉不是太会踩雷
Lucia: Because it’s not likely to be a miss.
Katrina: 百利甜是气泡酒还是什么酒
Katrina: Is Baileys a sparkling wine or what?
Lucia: 百利甜是一种甜酒
Lucia: Baileys is a kind of sweet liquor.
Lucia: 利口酒
Lucia: A liqueur.
Shure: 也不是香槟吧
Shure: It’s not champagne, right?
Shure: 是气泡酒
Shure: It's sparkling wine.
Lucia: 反正一般女生会比较不踩雷
Lucia: Anyway, girls usually don't make mistakes.
Tasha: 说要买瓶香槟
Tasha: Said we should buy a bottle of champagne.
Katrina: 香槟真的假的
Katrina: Champagne, really?
Katrina: 那个就是香槟
Katrina: That's the champagne.
Lucia:那个就行
Lucia: That one is fine.
Katrina: 北冰洋还要买吗
Katrina: Do we still need to buy Arctic Ocean?
Katrina: 哦可乐没了
Katrina: Oh, we're out of Coke.
Katrina: 我靠
Katrina: Damn.
Tasha: 茶
Tasha: Cannabis tea.
Katrina: 茶是什么
Katrina: What is cannabis tea?
Katrina: 茶这样写吗
Katrina: Is cannabis tea written like this?
Tasha: 直接叫茶吗
Tasha: Just call it cannabis tea?
Katrina: 哪个叫什么是茶
Katrina: Which one is called cannabis tea?
Katrina: 什么维他茶
Katrina: What Vita tea?
Katrina: 哦维他写了哈哈
Katrina: Oh, Vita, it's written, haha.
Lucia: 我刚才这句话要不要删掉了
Lucia: Should I delete that sentence I just said?
Jack: 我们还是希望中国的人
Jack: We still hope Chinese people...
Katrina: 你还需要草莓吗
Katrina: Do you still need strawberries?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 蓝莓是不是没拆
Tasha: The blueberries aren't opened, right?
Katrina: 蓝莓吃掉了
Katrina: The blueberries were eaten.
Katrina: 什么时候买的
Katrina: When did you buy them?
Tasha: 什么时候吃掉的
Tasha: When did you eat them?
Katrina: 上第一次买的那个
Katrina: The ones we bought the first time.
Katrina: 洗了那天不知道什么时候洗
Katrina: Washed them, don't know when we washed them.
Katrina: 蓝莓草莓
Katrina: Blueberries, strawberries.
Lucia: 因为因为那个如果再放好就坏了
Lucia: Because if we leave them any longer, they'll go bad.
Tasha: 那就买草莓和蓝莓还有
Tasha: Then buy strawberries and blueberries and...
Katrina: 青提
Katrina: Green grapes.
Katrina: 可以兑酒青提
Katrina: You can mix green grapes with alcohol.
Tasha: 青提还有榴莲啊
Tasha: Green grapes and durian too?
Katrina: 你要榴莲是吧
Katrina: You want durian, right?
Katrina: 你喜欢吃榴莲是不
Katrina: Do you like eating durian?
Jake:可以继续独家
Jake: You can continue exclusivity.
Lucia: 哎我们之前买那盒榴莲吃完了吗
Lucia: Hey, did we finish that box of durian we bought before?
Tasha: 他偷偷吃掉了
Tasha: He secretly ate it.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahaha.
Tasha: 你吃没吃啊
Tasha: Did you eat it?
Tasha: 你看他偷偷吃掉了
Tasha: Look, he secretly ate it.
Shure: 猫也挂着呢
Shure: The cat is also hanging around.
Shure: 我给你开global行不
Shure: How about I set the global for you?
Shure: 为什么
Shure: Why?
Jake:哎这边有电话
Jake: Hey, there's a call.
Jake:有个上海的电话
Jake: It's a call from Shanghai.
Shure: twinmod我都开了
Shure: I've already set the twinmod.
Katrina: 上海谁给我打电话
Katrina: Who's calling me from Shanghai?
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Katrina: 那明天就是那个串要买吗
Katrina: So, are we buying the skewers tomorrow?
Katrina: 烤吗
Katrina: Grilling them?
Katrina: 那就烤点串
Katrina: Then let's grill some skewers.
Katrina: 然后那个炭啊什么的都有了是吧
Katrina: And we have the charcoal and all that, right?
Katrina: 那些原料
Katrina: The ingredients.
Jake:炭没有
Jake: We don't have charcoal.
Katrina: 哦哦哦哦哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahahahaha.
Katrina: 明天还有啥流程
Katrina: What else is on the schedule for tomorrow?
Katrina: 这个等一会布置可以
Katrina: Can we set up this later?
Katrina: 还
Katrina: Also,
Katrina: 还还有那个如果说要唱歌的话
Katrina: Also, if we want to sing,
Katrina: 你音响能接话筒吗
Katrina: Can your speaker connect to a microphone?
Katrina: 有话筒吗
Katrina: Do you have a microphone?
Shure: 没有话筒
Shure: No microphone.
Jake:没有话筒怎么搞
Jake: How are we gonna do it without a microphone?
Shure: 买话筒
Shure: Buy a microphone.
Katrina: 租吧
Katrina: Rent one.
Nicous: 9块9 话筒
Nicous: 9.9 yuan microphone.
Katrina: 买那种就小小的一个话筒那么小
Katrina: Just buy a small one, a tiny microphone.
Shure: 大概一话筒就100多块钱搞一个
Shure: A decent microphone costs about 100 yuan.
Tasha: 租一个吧
Tasha: Let's rent one.
Shure: 次日达
Shure: Next-day delivery.
Tasha: 现在买还来得及吗
Tasha: Can we still buy one now?
Shure: 费劲
Shure: It's a hassle.
Alice:明天天气比今天再热一点
Alice: Tomorrow's weather will be hotter than today.
Jake:哦真的
Jake: Oh, really?
Tasha: 怎么要买空调吗
Tasha: Do we need to buy an AC?
其他人：哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahaha.
Jake:不买空调大风扇
Jake: No, just get a big fan.
其他人：买那个烤肉用的
Others: Buy one for grilling.
其他人：烤肉用的超大
Others: A huge one for grilling.
Shure: 你们回北邮吧
Shure: You guys should head back to Beiyou.
Tasha: 制冰风扇
Tasha: Ice-making fan
Katrina: 哎是不是那个小青柠
Katrina: Hey, isn't that the little lime?
Katrina: 还在呢
Katrina: It's still here.
Tasha: 在呢
Tasha: Yeah, it is.
Katrina: 对在
Katrina: Yes, it is.
Katrina: 芒果还需要吗
Katrina: Do we still need mango?
Katrina: 你做蛋糕的话啊
Katrina: If you're making a cake...
Katrina: 芒果还需要吗
Katrina: Do we still need mango?
Tasha: 不要了
Tasha: No, we don't.
Katrina: 不要了
Katrina: No, we don't.
Lucia: 应该买龙舌兰的
Lucia: We should have bought tequila.
Katrina: 那这次买龙舌兰
Katrina: Then let's buy tequila this time.
Lucia: 哦没事没事
Lucia: Oh, it's fine, it's fine.
Lucia: 我就随口一说
Lucia: I was just saying.
Lucia: 如果大家觉得能
Lucia: If everyone thinks it's okay...
Katrina: 要么就把朗姆换成龙舌兰都行
Katrina: Or we can just replace the rum with tequila, either way.
Katrina: 我不太懂
Katrina: I don't really know.
Lucia: 今天今天买酒还买朗姆吗
Lucia: Are we still buying rum today?
Katrina: 换那就换呗
Katrina: Let's just switch it then.
Lucia: 那就换龙舌兰呗
Lucia: Okay, let's switch to tequila.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Lucia: 就是大家可以尝尝不同的口味吗
Lucia: Everyone can try different flavors.
Katrina: 什么话筒
Katrina: What microphone?
Katrina: 有是吗
Katrina: Do we have it?
Shure: 话筒北邮有
Shure: There's a microphone at Beiyou.
Shure: 有他们来的时候给我取了就行
Shure: When they come, just get it for me.
Katrina: 借一下呗
Katrina: Just borrow it.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What is it?
其他人：推波波
Others: Push Bobo.
Lucia: 我还以为是小提琴
Lucia: I thought it was a violin.
Katrina: 你主要是你的那个缺还缺啥材料吗甜点
Katrina: Do you still need any other ingredients for your dessert?
Tasha: 好像不缺啥了
Tasha: Seems like we don't need anything else.
Shure: 如果是6个人去的话就可以
Shure: If there are 6 people going, it's okay.
Shure: 有个人能留在这帮我配环境
Shure: Someone can stay here to help me set up the environment.
Jake:哈哈哈要不然就是你吧
Jake: Hahaha, how about you do it?
Jack: 对那你可以在这配环境
Jack: Yeah, you can stay here and set up the environment.
Jack: 不是你先搞一个贝斯
Jack: You need to get a bass first.
Jack: 你贝斯如果搞好剩下就只等
Jack: Once you get the bass done, then we just wait.
Jack: 你可以把开创式装起来就走
Jack: You can set up the creative stuff and then go.
Jack: 回来就装好
Jack: When we get back, we'll set it up.
Shure: 他现在自己在这装呢
Shure: He's setting it up himself right now.
Shure: 我可以再开一个命令行一起装吗
Shure: Can I open another command line and set it up together?
Shure: 啊好
Shure: Ah, okay.
Shure: 那这个他5下载速度是500K每秒
Shure: So, his download speed is 500K per second.
Nicous: 到底发现还挺好吧
Nicous: Actually, it's pretty good, right?
Shure: 我估计差不多
Shure: I guess it's about right.
Shure: 回来他能装好都不错了这东西
Shure: If he can set it up when he gets back, that's good enough.
Jake:行啊走吧走吧
Jake: Okay, let's go.
Shure: 咱们全全员都去是吧
Shure: Are we all going?
Jake:全员都去
Jake: Everyone's going.
Jake:还是再打一辆吧
Jake: Maybe we should call another cab.
Jake:或者
Jake: Or...
Alice:我在家吧
Alice: I'll stay home.
Alice:我在家等着那个快递
Alice: I'll wait for the delivery.
Jake:紫堂不来了
Jake: Zitang's not coming.
Jake:行那
Jake: Okay then.
Jack: 56788个人
Jack: 56788 people.
Tasha: 12341234
Nicous: 对的一个人
Nicous: Yeah, one person.
Nicous: 四个人五
Nicous: Four people, five.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake:打车去哪啊
Jake: Where are we taking the cab to?
Jack: wherewherewhere
Jake:我们别去
Jake: Let's not go there.
Jake:我们换一家超市
Jake: Let's switch to another supermarket.
Katrina: 哼哼哼
Katrina: Hmph hmph hmph.
Shure: 那你们有山姆会员吗
Shure: Do you guys have a Sam's Club membership?
Jack: 建义那有
Jack: Jianyi has one.
Jack: 通州区万达
Jack: In Wanda, Tongzhou.
Jake:去万达是吧
Jake: We're going to Wanda, right?
Jack: 对稍微远一点
Jack: Yeah, it's a bit far.
Jack: 好像有通州区万达
Jack: I think there's one in Wanda, Tongzhou.
Nicous: 万达也近
Nicous: Wanda is also close.
Lucia: 哦那个在通州北苑呢
Lucia: Oh, that one's in Tongzhou Beiyuan.
Jack: 反正我好像上次看到了
Jack: Anyway, I think I saw it last time.
Shure: 只要有超市的地方要去
Shure: As long as there's a supermarket, we should go.
Lucia: 超市
Lucia: Supermarket.
Jake:超市儿
Jake: Supermarket.
Jack: 超市
Jack: Supermarket.
Choiszt: 那就万达呗
Choiszt: Then let's go to Wanda.
Choiszt: 然后卧槽
Choiszt: And oh damn.
Choiszt: 7公里
Choiszt: 7 kilometers.
Jack: 7公里开车20多分钟吧
Jack: 7 kilometers, it'll take more than 20 minutes by car.
Shure: 他是卡了吗
Shure: Did he get stuck?
Shure: 他怎么不动弹呢
Shure: Why isn't he moving?
Jake:万达超市是什么超市
Jake: What kind of supermarket is Wanda?
Shure: 永辉吧
Shure: Yonghui, I guess.
Jake:永辉
Jake: Yonghui.
Jack: 肯定很大
Jack: It must be huge.
Jake:可以可以那就去永辉
Jake: Alright, let's go to Yonghui then.
Choiszt: 半个小时
Choiszt: Half an hour.
Choiszt: 我看看还有没有
Choiszt: Let me check if there's anything else.
Shure: 你会你会配环境吗
Shure: Can you match the environment?
Jake:没买
Jake: Didn't buy it.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Jake:没设计出来
Jake: Couldn't design it.
Shure: 他这有一个完完整的教程
Shure: There's a complete tutorial here.
Shure: 你就按着他来就行
Shure: Just follow it step by step.
Choiszt: 要收谁米
Choiszt: Who's collecting rice?
Shure: 这个可能要装很久
Shure: This might take a long time to install.
Shure: 然后他他现在卡在这了
Shure: And now it's stuck here.
Shure: 他如果erro的话你就按下上键
Shure: If it shows an error, just press the up button.
Shure: 然后你再按下回车
Shure: Then hit Enter.
Shure: 哎算了我手机控制吧
Shure: Ah, never mind, I'll control it with my phone.
Jack: 你还可以这么牛逼
Jack: You can do that? That's impressive.
Nicous: 卧槽这个我真崩不住了
Nicous: Damn, I can't handle this.
Jack: 手机控电脑
Jack: Controlling the computer with your phone.
Katrina: 哈哈哦
Katrina: Haha, oh.
Jake:万达是吧
Jake: So, Wanda, right?
Choiszt: 哎这我附近有
Choiszt: Yeah, it's nearby.
Katrina: 我放冰箱去了
Katrina: I'll put it in the fridge.
Shure: 哦我直接把他一直带着不就得了吗
Shure: Oh, I'll just carry it with me all the time then.
Jake:物美很小
Jake: Wumart is small.
Jack: 建议万达
Jack: I recommend Wanda.
Choiszt: 没有看这外边看的还是挺大的
Choiszt: No, from the outside, it looks pretty big.
Shure: 没有我是
Shure: No, I...
Shure: 套了一个虚拟机
Shure: I set up a virtual machine.
Shure: 就是我用那个向日葵
Shure: I'm using Sunflower.
Shure: 先挂着我的那个Windows电脑
Shure: First, I connect it to my Windows computer.
Shure: 然后再用Windows电脑挂着我那个
Shure: And then I'll use a Windows computer to run my
Shure: 腾讯云的
Shure: Tencent Cloud
Shure: 那个服务器
Shure: server
Shure: 还行他真没有什么延时
Shure: It's not bad, there's really no delay
Shure: 他都是在北京你知道吧
Shure: It's all in Beijing, you know
Katrina: 你要看一下有没有蓝色吗
Katrina: Do you want to check if there's any blue?
Katrina: 好像有哎
Katrina: I think there is
Lucia: 哎我觉得可以
Lucia: Yeah, I think it's good
Katrina: 可以你拿吧
Katrina: Sure, you can take it
Katrina: 反正也做不完
Katrina: We can't finish it anyway
Katrina: 没几朵花
Katrina: There's not much
Katrina: 没事
Katrina: It's fine
Katrina: 反正是杨老板报销的
Katrina: Anyway, Jake's covering the cost
Jake:你电脑放外边真的不会被
Jake: Your computer outside really won't get
Katrina: 哦哦我电脑也在那
Katrina: Oh, oh, my computer is there too
Shure: 他晒不到吧
Shure: It won't get sun exposure, right?
Shure: 啊快晒到了是吗
Shure: Oh, is it getting sun exposure?
Katrina: 你有种似曾相识的感觉
Katrina: Do you have a sense of déjà vu?
Katrina: 费多大劲儿
Katrina: How much effort did it take?
Shure: 完蛋了我靠
Shure: We're screwed, damn it
Shure: 啊他淡了
Shure: Ah, it's faded
Shure: 他居然
Shure: He actually
Shure: 完成拍套式的安装了啊
Shure: completed the installation of the set!
Jack: 这么快你说500K我不信啊
Jack: So fast, you said 500K, I don't believe it
Shure: 那我估计就是他上午的时候
Shure: I guess he cached some of it in the morning
Shure: 缓存了一部分了
Shure: Cached some of it
Jake:装了多少遍啊
Jake: How many times did he install it?
Katrina: 还有充电宝吗
Katrina: Is there still a power bank?
Shure: 有
Shure: Yes
Katrina: 还有充电宝没找到
Katrina: Still couldn't find the power bank
Katrina: OK谢谢
Katrina: OK, thanks
Alice:他什么时候才能把我们的快递送到呢
Alice: When will he deliver our package?
Katrina: 所有的快递都要跟他说他才拿吗
Katrina: Does he need to be told about every package to get them?
Katrina: 还是说他直接报他的尾号
Katrina: Or does he just report his last digits
Katrina: 直接全部都拿过来
Katrina: and collect all of them?
Alice:不知道
Alice: I don't know
Alice:你要送吗
Alice: Do you want to deliver them?
Jack: 刘帅改变了主意
Jack: Choiszt changed his mind
Jack: 他决定先去看
Jack: He decided to check first
Jack: 因为他觉得档次不如永辉
Jack: Because he thinks it's not as classy as Yonghui
Jake:他他先去看看是什么意思
Jake: He went to see what it means first.
Jack: 先去看看档次够不够
Jack: To see if it's high enough quality.
Jake:所以我们先去哪儿
Jake: So where are we going first?
Shure: 刘帅才干嘛去了
Shure: Where did Choiszt go?
Jake:他在外面坐着啊
Jake: He's sitting outside.
Shure: 啊哈
Shure: Aha.
Shure: 那我们现在干嘛
Shure: So what are we doing now?
Jake:打电话问问呗
Jake: Let's call and ask.
Jake:问问物美你档次够不够啊
Jake: Ask if Wumart is high enough quality.
Shure: 没办法京爷就是这个样子的
Shure: No way, that's just how King is.
Lucia: 你什么档次也敢出镜
Lucia: What quality do you think you have to be on camera?
Jack: 京爷
Jack: King.
Shure: 脑袋炸的时候
Shure: When your head explodes.
Katrina: 蔫了
Katrina: Wilted.
Katrina: 我靠
Katrina: Oh my god.
Katrina: 真用公费买了一只jellycat
Katrina: Really bought a Jellycat with public funds.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Katrina: 我说我真用公费买了一只
Katrina: I said I really bought one with public funds.
Katrina: Jelly cat
Katrina: Jellycat.
Katrina: 我靠这么多快递
Katrina: Wow, so many packages.
Shure: 你买了什么Jelly cat
Shure: What Jellycat did you buy?
Katrina: 我买了蝴蝶
Katrina: I bought a butterfly.
Shure: 你用公费买了Jelly cat是吗
Shure: You really bought a Jellycat with public funds?
Lucia: 哎我也买了一只
Lucia: Hey, I bought one too.
Lucia: 因为它颜色刚好是我计划的颜色一样
Lucia: Because its color matches my plan.
Shure: 送给
Shure: To give to...
Katrina: 那可不那送给自己的
Katrina: Of course, to give to myself.
Katrina: 不会为了这个
Katrina: Not for...
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 人送我还差不多我送
Katrina: It's better if people give it to me rather than me giving.
Shure: 那你要追人家你就应该主动一点
Shure: If you want to chase someone, you should be more proactive.
Katrina: 导游任务上追
Katrina: Chase through tour guide tasks.
Katrina: 这个叫吸引attract
Katrina: This is called attracting.
Shure: 哎呀你快歇歇 吧
Shure: Oh come on, give it a rest.
Katrina: 哎呀哈哈哈哈呀
Katrina: Haha, oh my gosh.
Shure: 看你是跑的快还是拉的快
Shure: Let's see if you can run faster or pull faster.
Katrina: 无所谓啊
Katrina: Doesn't matter.
Shure: （歌词）爱情是你独特的味道
Shure: (Lyrics) Love is your unique flavor.
Shure: （歌词）在我地球闪耀
Shure: (Lyrics) Shining on my earth.
Shure: （歌词）别人都不了只有你知道
Shure: (Lyrics) Others don't understand, only you know
Shure: （歌词）因为你世界不再单调
Shure: (Lyrics) Because of you, the world is no longer dull
Shure: （歌词）你的微笑你明白就很好
Shure: (Lyrics) Your smile, you understand, and that's enough
Lucia: 你明天跳吧
Lucia: Dance tomorrow
Jake:你明天直接跳吧
Jake: Just dance tomorrow
Jake:给你搭舞台
Jake: We'll set up a stage for you
Jake:我们去永辉问问有没有舞台
Jake: Let's go ask Yonghui if they have a stage
Shure: 好
Shure: Sure
Shure: 刘老根大舞台
Shure: The grand stage at Liu Laogen
Lucia: 你能学8小时速成的
Lucia: Can you do the 8-hour crash course?
Lucia: 已经速成的
Lucia: It's already a crash course
Lucia: 非常好了
Lucia: It's really good
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Exactly, exactly
Jake:学出来的吗
Jake: Did you learn it?
Lucia: 刚那个动作不是
Lucia: That move earlier wasn't
Lucia: 那天那个
Lucia: That day’s move
Shure: 不是跟那没有关系
Shure: It's not related to that
Shure: 根据歌词solo的
Shure: I soloed based on the lyrics
Shure: （歌词）情是你独特的味道
Shure: (Lyrics) Love is your unique flavor
Shure: （歌词）在我地球闪耀
Shure: (Lyrics) Shining on my earth
Shure: （歌词）别人都不了
Shure: （歌词）只有你知道
Shure: （歌词）董小姐
Shure: （歌词）你熄灭了烟
Shure: （歌词）你说昨晚
Shure: 还没给钱
Katrina: 你小子
Shure: 怎么样是不是很很很董小姐
Lucia: 这个问题有价值啊
Lucia: 终于不再是弱智吧的问题了
Shure: 呵AI永远理理解不了这些问题
Shure: 哈哈因为他没有这方面的
Lucia: 哈哈哈的什么
Jack: 你可以去采数据然后喂给他
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: 好的好的
Tasha: 好吗好的
Shure: 那今晚今晚就把女朋友叫过来
Lucia: 哈哈哈别
Lucia: 哈哈哈这话说的
Lucia: 咱屋里一下多了好多人
Lucia: There are suddenly so many people in our room.
Shure: 好啊好的
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure: 不要再玩我们家大冰的梗了好吗
Shure: Can we stop joking about our big ice?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 你坏
Lucia: You're bad.
Shure: 大冰为止
Shure: Big ice till now.
Alice:大冰打人算群殴吗
Alice: If big ice hits someone, is it considered group fighting?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈这算了吧
Alice: Hahahahahaha, let's consider it.
Alice:怎么不算一网红
Alice: Why isn't he considered an internet celebrity?
Shure: 哇他可以biu的一下甩出来你看
Shure: Wow, he can fling it out just like that, look.
Katrina: 哇这是什么
Katrina: Wow, what is that?
Shure: 哇太酷了吧
Shure: Wow, that's so cool.
Shure: 没有一个男生能拒绝
Shure: No guy can refuse this.
Shure: 一个非常直的棍子
Shure: A very straight stick.
Shure: bravo
Shure: Bravo.
Shure: do you know bravo
Shure: Do you know bravo?
Shure: （歌词）月里来是新年啊
Shure: (lyrics) The moon brings the New Year.
Shure: （歌词）大年初一头一天啊
Shure: (lyrics) The first day of the new year.
Shure: （歌词）家家团圆味啊
Shure: (lyrics) Every family reunites.
Shure: 咱们什么时候出发呀
Shure: When are we leaving?
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Alice:问什么时候来
Alice: Ask when they're coming.
Alice:送快递
Alice: To deliver the package.
Jake:我这车还有9分8分钟到
Jake: My car will be here in about 9 minutes and 8 minutes.
Jake:这狗是每个人放门口
Jake: This dog is at everyone's doorstep.
Jake:我们也得做点
Jake: We also need to do something.
Jack: 哦这是要干嘛
Jack: Oh, what's this for?
Alice:我的狗还没啊
Alice: My dog isn't here yet.
Lucia: 耳机还没
Lucia: The headphones aren't here yet.
Lucia: 还要给它夹花花吗
Lucia: Do we need to put flowers on it?
Alice:不是我那个腿还没剪呢
Alice: No, I haven't cut its leg yet.
Lucia: 啊你后面这样
Lucia: Ah, you mean like this?
Lucia: 没事没事这样已经很好看了
Lucia: It's okay, it already looks good like this.
Alice:面条子
Alice: Noodles.
Alice:剪刀在哪啊
Alice: Where are the scissors?
Lucia: 套装勿拆
Lucia: Do not open the set.
Lucia: 因为内有恶犬
Lucia: Because there's a vicious dog inside.
Lucia: 哎可以可以
Lucia: Hey, that's good.
Lucia: 给他写给他写套装勿拆内有恶犬
Lucia: Write on it, "Do not open the set, there's a vicious dog inside."
Jake:剪刀这边有
Jake: The scissors are over here.
Alice:这个不太利索
Alice: This one isn't very sharp.
Alice:另一个在哪
Alice: Where's the other one?
Lucia: 另一个其实也不太利
Lucia: The other one isn't very sharp either.
Lucia: 比这能好点不
Lucia: Is it better than this one?
Jake:菜刀强一点
Jake: The kitchen knife is a bit better.
Jake:这有俩菜刀
Jake: There are two kitchen knives here.
Jake:菜刀不能控制方向呀
Jake: You can't control the direction with a kitchen knife.
Jake:你只能直着剪
Jake: You can only cut straight.
Jake:给菜刀烫头
Jake: Give the kitchen knife a haircut.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:那
Jake: Well...
Jake:上面有吗
Jake: Is there one on top?
Katrina: 问你个问题
Katrina: Can I ask you a question?
Katrina: 北京西站离什刹海远吗
Katrina: Is Beijing West Station far from Shichahai?
Lucia: 北京西什刹海好像在很中间的地方
Lucia: Beijing West and Shichahai seem to be in the middle.
Alice:什刹海在中间
Alice: Shichahai is in the middle.
Katrina: 什刹海在
Katrina: Shichahai is...
Katrina: 东直门是不是
Katrina: Is it near Dongzhimen?
Alice:左西右东
Alice: Left is west, right is east.
Lucia: 对我觉得很中间
Lucia: Yeah, I think it's in the middle.
Katrina: 西城区嘛
Katrina: It's in Xicheng District, right?
Lucia: 就是这个这个这个大水
Lucia: Yeah, this big water area.
Lucia: 这个附近应该就是什刹海
Lucia: It should be near Shichahai.
Lucia: 我要没记错的话
Lucia: If I remember correctly.
Lucia: 我也有一段时间没来了
Lucia: I haven't been here for a while.
Jake:走个两环
Jake: Walk around the second ring road.
Jake:跨两环
Jake: Cross the second ring road.
其他人：哦哦
Others: Oh, oh.
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
Jake:相对于通州而言
Jake: Compared to Tongzhou.
Jake:我们人在北京
Jake: We're in Beijing.
Jake:相对于通州而言
Jake: Compared to Tongzhou.
Jake:北京市区
Jake: It's downtown Beijing.
Jack: 我想我在上海这个地方确实是近
Jack: I think it's pretty close compared to Shanghai.
Jack: 就可以走走路
Jack: You can walk there.
Lucia: 我觉得我本科都不怎么出学校
Lucia: I rarely left the campus during my undergrad.
Lucia: 出去学校太累了
Lucia: Leaving campus was too tiring.
Jack: 我是不是要打车
Jack: Should I take a taxi?
Jack: 所以啊
Jack: So, yeah.
Lucia: 你是在紫金宿舍还是在南区
Lucia: Are you staying in the Zijing dorms or the south campus?
Jack: 南区现在已经是高贵的强基计划
Jack: The South Campus is now part of the prestigious Qiangji program.
Jack: 新雅和强基
Jack: Xinya and Qiangji.
Lucia: 经管男生
Lucia: The Econ boys.
Lucia: 现在是在我
Lucia: They're with me now.
Lucia: 因为我
Lucia: Because I...
Lucia: 我们那会好像他们最早在31号楼
Lucia: Back then, they were first in Building 31.
Lucia: 但后来好像搬到了南区
Lucia: But later, they seemed to have moved to the South Campus.
Jack: 现在应该还在紫金吧
Jack: They should still be in Zijin, right?
Lucia: 紫金去上课真是把人累死
Lucia: Going to class in Zijin is exhausting.
Jack: 确实所以我从大二开始就不上课
Jack: That's why I stopped attending classes from sophomore year.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈excuse me
Lucia: Hahahahahaha, excuse me.
Jake:解决了问题
Jake: Problem solved.
Jake:从根本上解决
Jake: Solved from the root.
Jack: 非常非常好解决
Jack: Very, very well solved.
Jack: 就睡睡到自然醒
Jack: Just sleep until you naturally wake up.
Jack: 然后然后去图书馆
Jack: Then go to the library.
Jack: 是记得去图书馆
Jack: Remember to go to the library.
Jack: 这个南区跟紫金基本一样
Jack: The South Campus and Zijin are pretty much the same.
Lucia: 去图书馆我应该不用爬那个好汉堡
Lucia: To go to the library, I don't need to climb that steep hill.
Jake:走吧来
Jake: Let's go, come on.
Lucia: 要命了
Lucia: It's exhausting.
Lucia: 现在想想我都心有余悸
Lucia: Thinking about it now still gives me chills.
Alice:我的狗放在门口吧
Alice: I'll leave my dog at the door.
Lucia: 我都行
Lucia: I'm fine with that.
Katrina: 几几几带几啊
Katrina: How many do you need to bring?
Katrina: 几带几啊
Katrina: How many to bring?
Katrina: 你的车能坐5个啊
Katrina: Can your car fit 5 people?
Choiszt: 对算上我5个啊
Choiszt: Yeah, including me, 5 people.
Katrina: 那我跟你坐吧
Katrina: Then I'll ride with you.
Katrina: 1234
Katrina: One, two, three, four.
Lucia: 我要给他俩拍个照
Lucia: I want to take a picture of them.
Choiszt: 你你们两个是怎么
Choiszt: How did you two...
Nicous: 一个叫小猫一个叫小兔
Nicous: One's called Little Cat, the other's Little Rabbit.
Choiszt:  123那修硕不去去吗啊
Choiszt: One, two, three, isn't Shure coming?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Katrina: 我都背上了
Katrina: I've already packed.
Choiszt: 那多一个人
Choiszt: Then there's one extra person.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Choiszt: 因为有一个人跟靖康主要限坐6个人
Choiszt: Because one person with health issues limits it to six people.
Katrina: 哪6个他不去
Katrina: Which six? He's not going.
Katrina: 12345 OK
Shure: 纸狮子
Shure: Paper lion
Alice:纸兔纸狗子
Alice: Paper rabbit, paper dog
Shure: follow me
Shure: Follow me
Katrina: 走吧走吧
Katrina: Let's go, let's go
Shure: 纸狮子
Shure: Paper lion
Lucia: 死柿子
Lucia: Dead persimmon
Shure: 屎柿子是什么东西
Shure: What is a poop persimmon?
Lucia: 石柿子
Lucia: Stone persimmon
Jake:开车在那
Jake: The car is over there
Shure: 那我跟那边
Shure: Then I'll go over there
Shure: 关了
Shure: Turn it off
Shure: 啊好
Shure: Ah, okay
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Jack: 你这车有BIOS
Jack: Your car has BIOS.
Jack: 他这车BIOS不是很强
Jack: His car's BIOS isn't very strong.
Katrina: 哎微微呢
Katrina: Hey, where's Tasha?
Jake:哎那
Jake: Hey, there.
Katrina: 哦哦在这
Katrina: Oh, oh, here she is.
Lucia: 这给他装回去放门口吧
Lucia: Put this back by the door.
Jake:哦这谁做的
Jake: Oh, who did this?
Katrina: 可乐拿一个
Katrina: Get a Coke.
Katrina: 诶吓我一跳
Katrina: Whoa, you scared me.
Katrina: 呐呐呐 6瓶够吧
Katrina: Here, here, here. Six bottles enough?
Shure: 不够
Shure: Not enough.
Katrina: 真的吗不是只有调调酒吗
Katrina: Really? We're just mixing drinks, right?
Shure: 大家喝呢
Shure: Everyone's drinking, you know.
Shure: 就是只给来了gas的喝水是吗
Shure: So, only the guests get water?
Katrina: 喝RIO吧
Katrina: Let's drink RIO.
Katrina: 想喝那个桃子味的
Katrina: I want the peach-flavored one.
Shure: RIO
Shure: RIO.
Katrina: 我想喝这个桃子
Katrina: I want this peach one.
Katrina: 喝这个吧
Katrina: Let's drink this.
Katrina: 要不要直接拿一提啊
Katrina: Should we just grab a whole pack?
Shure: 行
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 3个这3个味的都好喝
Katrina: These three flavors are all good.
Katrina: 卧槽
Katrina: Whoa.
Katrina: 不是
Katrina: Wait.
Katrina: 青提蓝草莓和黄桃
Katrina: Green grape, blueberry, and yellow peach.
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 二锅头你们东北那喝二锅头是吗
Katrina: Erguotou, do you guys drink Erguotou in the northeast?
Shure: 北京喝二锅头
Shure: Beijing drinks Erguotou.
Katrina: 北京喝二锅头
Katrina: Beijing drinks Erguotou.
Katrina: 雪花啤酒
Katrina: Snow beer.
Shure: 这是那种复古包装的雪花啤酒
Shure: This is the retro-packaged Snow beer.
Katrina: 对没见过这种
Katrina: Right, I haven't seen this kind.
Katrina: 我没见过这种的哎
Katrina: I haven't seen this kind before.
Katrina: 苏打水要拿吗上次的
Katrina: Should we get soda water, like last time?
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Katrina: 哎元气森林
Katrina: Hey, Yuanqi Forest.
Katrina: 这下有元气森林了吧
Katrina: Now we have Yuanqi Forest, right?
Shure: 葡萄味的是吧
Shure: The grape one, right?
Katrina: 对对对感觉那葡萄汁兑的一般般
Katrina: Yeah, yeah, it feels like the grape juice is just average.
Katrina: 直接拿这个
Katrina: Just take this.
Katrina: 拿几瓶呢
Katrina: How many bottles should we take?
Shure: 最后喝不了你就带走当奖金了是吧
Shure: If we can't finish drinking it, you can take it back as a prize, right?
Katrina: 待会
Katrina: Later.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 然后到时候哎
Shure: And then at that time...
Shure: 打包回去吧
Shure: Just pack it up and take it back.
Katrina: 带回我们宿舍
Katrina: Bring it back to our dorm.
Katrina: 我们宿舍有福了
Katrina: Our dorm will be blessed.
Katrina: 有点像那种打猎回来
Katrina: It's kind of like coming back from a hunt.
Shure: 孩子们
Shure: Kids.
Katrina: 我回来了
Katrina: I'm back.
Katrina: 订的24号下午2点的票
Katrina: I booked tickets for the 24th at 2 PM.
Katrina: 哎杯子打碎了还够吗
Katrina: Hey, the cup is broken, is there enough?
Katrina: 可不可以直接让管家拿
Katrina: Can we just have the housekeeper take it?
Katrina: 就不自己买了
Katrina: So we don't have to buy it ourselves.
Katrina: 反也带不走
Katrina: We can't take it anyway.
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Shure: 要不都咱们这次要用一次性的东西吗
Shure: How about we use disposable things this time?
Katrina: 拿一次性杯子
Katrina: Use disposable cups.
Shure: 啊我不想刷了
Shure: Ah, I don't want to wash them.
Shure: 虽然不符合我们这个Eagle life的理念吧
Shure: Although it doesn't fit our Eagle life philosophy.
Nicous: 但我们不能
Nicous: But we can't...
Shure: 我们我们能用一次性餐具之类的吗
Shure: Can we use disposable tableware and stuff?
Katrina: 那上次那个杯子打碎几个
Katrina: How many cups did we break last time?
Katrina: 那明天人更多了
Katrina: There'll be more people tomorrow.